important thing is is that
they are actually innately attracted
that's what i'm saying girls start off
the feminine energy does want the man
though they want the masculine um but
because they're jaded and then they
they had to what do you mean because
they're they want the masculine because
because i genuinely feel that they
i'll say this from personal experience
i
as a as a young girl that's why i was
remembered like i i have a very
traditional family my mother stayed at
home took care of the kids my father was
the breadwinner for me that is normal
that is what i saw myself envisioned
myself with and
sadly because times have changed
um my my mom started saying you can't
just you know rely on a guy you've got
to also have your craft you you've got
to have something to bring to the table
so i agreed i said yeah of course so i
went out there i spent the time on
myself and i really like worked on
myself try to be a good you know like a
good society person in society
but the thing is then in that journey i
became too masculine right i overshot
and
then i'm starting to give pro vibes and
and then of course
then these girls are asking why am i not
getting the guy the masculine guy well
one
um you're too masculine i know that
because i was there once i had to teach
myself i had to remind myself that i
need to tone it down there are certain
times where that's appropriate such as
when i'm in a more work situation and i
have to be more decisive but when i'm on
a date
i am different i i want i want a
masculine men i defined i actually
looked at myself and i said
what do i want do i want a feminine man
or do i want a maximum why did why did
your mom why do you think your mom um
encouraged you to be masculine if it's
it seemed to have worked out well for
her she got to provide her husband and
like very sad actually we had this
conversation and my mom said to me she
said in my times she said guys just came
up to me all the time now i will say
this my mom's very feminine she's like
the damsel in distress so she does
attract guys anyways
but she was saying like i would use to
walk on the street and i will see great
quality men everywhere like i feel like
i can just pick them off the street
they're all great
but i don't know she said i don't know
what's going on she was like it makes me
really sad but i feel like
guys are not as high caliber anymore and
i'm worried for my daughter i'm scared
that they're going to not be able to
deal with themselves
and they don't have that
person either so so to compensate she's
pushing me on the other direction of
being self-sufficient but the danger of
that is that it's over it was overshot i
think that's a common problem now so
yeah like you said your mom's pushing
you that way just to go back on your
point that you made before the fact that
you realized you was too masculine that
is
that is what
men i think today are
asking women to do is just for me i've
got female friends that i've got
boyfriends and they sometimes they ask
me for advice and i just tell them look
in the mirror and i don't and i say look
in the mirror and i'm not talking about
look at your body your face i'm saying
look in the mirror
and look at the person you're being when
you're going to restaurants like how are
you trying to you trying to dominate the
situation when you go to a family
gathering trying to dominate like you
have to let your man be a man
and exactly women find a problem yeah do
you guys think there's a shortage of
husbands or wives
depends on one occasion i guess wives
um i said that that's an interesting
question um
i'd say
i'd say there's a shortage on husbands
because
men like it's just not worth it like any
logical man which most men it's safe to
say illogical i'd say it just doesn't
make sense
oh cause they don't want to get married
yeah what you're saying okay what do you
think shortage of husbands or wives it
depends on where as i said in the west
in the west so so this is england u.s
[Music]
i i i don't i'll be honest i don't pick
one pick one um i would say
men
shortage of husbands
wives
um i can i'd like you to so you think
you sort of explained a little bit you
think it's because men don't want to get
married yeah um i i don't think it's
that men don't want to get married like
i'd love to get married but to the right
woman that i know that wouldn't like
just
check my [ __ ] you know what i mean
because i have very big plans for my
future and i'm not trying to risk it for
no one because like if a woman can marry
me for a year and take everything that
i've worked for over all these years and
put every ounce of effort into
then like
as someone who wants to get into
business that does not seem like good
business you know that sounds like a bad
move
so me that's that's more of a point to
where i think there's less wives so i
think traditionally and even currently
men
caught women we go out and we try to
find a woman
so if we can't find a woman i think
that's the problem now it's like we're
not we're not making it blunt enough
like
men don't want to get married to the
current women and we have multiple
reasons for that
like let's not talk about only fans
let's not talk about masculine women
like it's it's simple like we just don't
think women are good enough now for us
to settle down and marry
so do you think that women don't think
they're good enough for men or men don't
think they're good or do you think it's
um because i think that like women don't
think men are good enough for them even
if they're average
yeah that's the problem isn't it yeah
yeah i think because if you look in
history i don't
i think women dated and married average
guys historically because a lot a
question i ask on my show often is like
how much does your submission cost
and um and i say like to the point that
like if you said quit your job tomorrow
be with the kids you'd do it yeah i've
seen you ask them for the saturday and
they always say six figures even if
they're fives even though that's the
percent how much people how much men in
the world don't see yeah and so then the
next question is always are you a top 10
girl and they say no and so it's like
you have girls that are not top 10
asking for a top ten percent outcomes in
order to submit i think the word submit
bothers women
just the word submit bothers them they
don't want dismiss uh control to be
honest i think they uh i've heard this
before someone i'm not sure where but uh
i heard that women tend to think
submission means slavery like they think
what the man says
is just
absolutely final without reason you know
what i mean when
submission really is just um
you know it's not that you don't get a
say in the matter it's just that there's
a leader and you're a second in command
there's someone in primary command
but you're still in second in command
you have a lot of influence too it's
like because you can
i mean every every person knows like
that couple that's like really cute
we're like even even though the guy's in
charge like the woman's kind of in
charge because she's just so feminine
and kind of can get him to like see her
point of view you get there's a couple
that comes to your head right i said
okay i'm gonna give you an example it's
a little bit extreme but you actually
see the very clear
actually this will it's controversial if
you think about it but it's the
healthiest relationships
are from the bdsm
community and i will i will explain why
because i need you
the reason why i say it's healthy is in
order to
be
able to be in that type of relationship
because it is so extreme to the point
where sometimes there is a chance of
death yeah
because people engage in such extreme
activities
you need extreme trust in order to get
into it is there is there any data that
backs this up so the the idea no this
just sounds like this sounds crazy to me
so i i know i'm i'm gonna give you the
example okay
because things are so extreme you're not
just going to do it even though it's a
fantasy you're not going to do it unless
you trust that person it's not going to
actually kill you does that make sense
so you have to discuss all the details
you